So we have seen that moving from 1-bit predictor
to 2-bit predictor improves things. Primarily because the one
off occurrences of the other behavior are not going
to change it, our complete decision. So now the question
is, if the increase in the predictor size this
way worked. Why not do the 3-bit predictor or a
4-bit predictor? The bad part of using more bits
per predictor is that the cost goes up in proportion
to how many bits we need. We still need to have
the same number of predictor entries in order so that each
branch has its own predictor entry and not share it with
another branch that behaves differently. So, for the same number of
entries, we will have, this doubles the cost, this is going to
add another 50% to the cost, and so on, so we
are increasing the cost. It might be worth it if the
prediction accuracy is improving. So, the good side is that sometimes
the branch prediction accuracy does improve as you go
to 3-bits or 4-bits. When? Well, adding to 3-bits
or 4-its is going to increase the [UNKNOWN], of four.
A longer time, we will keep guessing the old
way, even though decisions are going the other way.
So really, the only time when this is good,
is when anomalous outcomes come in streaks. If you
have a streak of, for example, not taken all
of the time, and then it happens that you
have taken, taken very often. After that and then again
not taken for awhile then actually having a 3-bit
predictor would solve the problem of being convinced the other
way when the taken taken happens. But the real
question is, how often do we really have in real
programs that anomalous outcomes come in streaks? And the
answer is not very often. So what we might have
is that the 3-bit predictor might be worth it, but
definitely not the 4-bit predictor. So somehow we really want to
have either a 2-bit predictor or a 3-bit predictor. And most
of the time, we're just fine with a 2-bit predictor. We're
getting most of the benefits we would get with more
bits for a lower cost. So we really should stay with
a 2-bit predictor and maybe move to 3-bits if we really,
really want to. But if moving to more bits like this
is not helping us, then the question
becomes, but how do we then improve prediction
beyond the 2-bit predictor? We have already seen
that neither 1-bit nor 2-bit work really well
when we have things like not-taken, taken, not-taken,
taken, etc. And now, a human being that
looks at this sequence not-taken, taken, not-taken, taken,
etc., will correctly guess that the next outcome
here will probably be not-taken, followed by taken,
and so on. So this branch turns out
to be perfectly predictable, it's just that it's
not predictable with a 1-bit or 2-bit predictor.